er ist eine der meist gesuchten personen
europas janácek 40 jahre alt geboren in
wien letzter job vorstand bei wirecard
seine flucht ist der vorläufige
höhepunkt eines finanz wirtschaftskrimis
es geht um verschwundene milliarden
lobbyismus im kanzleramt russische
geheimdienste und bespitzelung von
journalisten
sie überwachten uns sie versuchten uns
zu hacken nicht nur mehrere meiner
kollegen bei der financial times sondern
auch investoren shortseller research es
ist eine geschichte wie ein deutsches
unternehmen aktionäre die
bundesfinanzaufsicht wirtschaftsprüfer
und die politik jahrelang täuscht und
obwohl es schon fragen am
geschäftsmodell gab keiner richtig
hinschaut voll auf den leim gegangen
juni 2020 früher vormittag jan
marschalek vertriebsvorstand von
wirecard verlässt den firmensitz ihm
wurde soeben fristlos gekündigt
10 43 lässt wirecard die bombe platzen
1,9 milliarden euro fehlen in der bilanz
marschalek lässt sich zum flughafen
frankfurt fahren
eine abenteuerliche flucht beginnt
während er flieht werden die ersten
wirecard manager festgenommen
insgesamt sind es die tatvorwürfe des
gewerbsmäßigen bandenbetrugs der untreue
der unrichtigen darstellung der
marktmanipulation in mehreren fällen
in wirklichkeit war den beschuldigten
spätestens seit ende 2015 klar dass der
wirecard konzern mit den tatsächlichen
geschäften insgesamt verluste erzielt
wahrscheinlich habt ihr bis vor kurzem
noch nie etwas von wirecard gehört
wirecard hat sich auf bargeldlose
zahlungssysteme spezialisiert das heißt
sie wickeln das geschäft zwischen dem
kunden der mit kredit oder ec karte
zahlt und dem händler ab viel springt
bei so einer transaktion nicht aus erst
eine hohe anzahl von transaktionen macht
das geschäft rentabel und bei diesen
zahlen soll wirecard jahre lang
polier tagen das ständige wachstum der
firma lockt millionenschwere geldgeber
an die am erfolg mit kassieren wollen
vorstandsvorsitzender markus braun und
vertriebsvorstand jan marschalek wissen
anscheinend was diese investoren hören
wollen und sammeln milliarden ein um
sich gehör auf höchster politischer
ebene zu verschaffen
hilft ihnen ein umtriebiger ex
bundesminister und nun lobbyist karl
theodor zu guttenberg er wird für das
betrügerische unternehmen bei der
bundeskanzlerin haben sie für mich auch
nochmal neue abgründe aufgetan uns wurde
gesagt vom bundeskanzleramt dass herr zu
guttenberg einen termin bekommen hat als
ex minister und freund der kanzlerin
und dann war aber offensichtlich
komplett als berater als lobbyist tätig
gegenüber der bundeskanzlerin und er war
ja sehr erfolgreich innerhalb von 24
stunden stand die wirecard ag die vorher
nicht auf der liste der bundeskanzlerin
stand auf der liste
die dann die bundeskanzlerin gegenüber
china formuliert hat das geschieht auf
merkels china-reise 2009/10 ein jahr
zuvor ist wirecard in den dax
aufgestiegen und gehört nun zu den
wertvollsten deutschen unternehmen an
der börse zeitweise ist wirecard
wertvoller als die deutsche bank der
aktienkurs beträgt damals 190 euro
solche zahlen locken viele groß und
klein aktionäre an die verlassen sich
auf die ergebnisse der wirtschaftsprüfer
idw
deren aufgabe ist es seit 2009 die
bilanzen von wirecard zu überprüfen und
die sollen immer tadellos gewesen sein
auch reinhard frisse sieht in wirecard
eine sichere anlage
2015 kauf der apotheker für 5000 euro
wirecard-aktien zur damaligen zeit haben
wir das erste mal dass ec cash gerät
bekommen und das hat mich auf die idee
gebracht weil eben die nachfrage nach
diesen geräten und nach diesen
bezahlmöglichkeiten steigt auch hier
wollen sie die apotheke immer mehr
gestiegen ist seit ich gesagt habe das
ist eigentlich zukunftstechnologie und
wenn ich darin investieren
dann verliert man geld eben nicht im
ergebnis war alles weg
einer der früh an den zahlen zweifelt
ist denn max autor bei der financial
times 2015 äußert er in einem artikel
erste zweifel an der erfolgsgeschichte
wirecard die geschäfte undurchsichtig
das unternehmen weniger profitabel als
dargestellt
wohlmöglich alles ein gigantischer
betrug so seine einschätzung
weitere artikel folgen und die reaktion
von wirecard mehr als filmreif
sie haben einige sehr aggressive anwälte
eingesetzt daran sind wir gewöhnt aber
sie überwachten uns sie versuchten uns
zu hacken nicht nur mehrere meiner
kollegen bei der financial times sondern
auch investoren shortseller research ist
sie alle wurden überwacht wir
berichteten über eine große überwachungs
operation in london im letzten jahr bei
der finanzfachleute verfolgt und
fotografiert wurde
die financial times vermutet dass
marschalek der kontakte zu
geheimdiensten in russland haben soll
diese aktion gesteuert hat und der plan
hat erfolg die berichterstattung der
zeitung wird in frage gestellt
vor allem in deutschland anfang 2009 10
dann neue vorwürfe wieder von der
financial times
wirecard sei in geldwäsche verwickelt
und manipuliere seine bücher der
großteil der asiatischen partner wären
erfunden
als wir über die probleme in der asien-
zentrale von wirecard berichteten
tretet ihr firma den spieß um wirecard
beschuldigte uns wir würden unsere
eigene geschichte vor der
veröffentlichung durch stechen damit
irgendjemand von fallenden aktienkursen
profitiert das war natürlich völlig
haltlos
doch es gelang wirecard den ruf der
financial times zu untergraben und
wieder scheinbar cards methoden
erfolgreich unglaublicher höhepunkt die
bundesanstalt für
finanzdienstleistungsaufsicht kurz bafin
erstattet im april 2009 10 strafanzeige
gegen den mc ram wegen angeblicher
marktmanipulation
um die vorwürfe der bilanzfälschung zu
entkräften beauftragt wirecard im
oktober 2009 10
kpmg die buchhaltung gesondert zu
überprüfen
im juni 2020 platzt dann die bombe 1,9
milliarden euro die auf philippinischen
konten liegen sollen existieren nur auf
dem papier
das war ja karthaus bricht zusammen und
muss insolvenz beantragen aktienkurs nun
90 cent
mittlerweile hat die bafin die anzeige
gegen die financial times zurückgezogen
und im bundestag fordert die opposition
einen untersuchungsausschuss zum fall
wirecard vor dem sich dann wohl auch
bafin chef felix muff feld stellen
müssen bestenfalls kann man sagen die
bafin war da blauäugig sie ist der
wirecard ag da voll auf den leim
gegangen aber das ist nicht die rolle
der aufsicht die rolle der aufsicht ist
es marktmanipulationen festzustellen
dann in alle richtungen zu ermitteln und
hier hatte die bafin ganz offenbar einen
blinden fleck in richtung wirecard ag
selber während wirecard
vorstandsvorsitzender markus braun in
untersuchungshaft sitzt ist sein partner
in crime marschalek weiterhin auf der
flucht
eine erste spur auf die philippinen
erweist sich als falsch
die rechercheplattform berlin kat hat
marschalek sweg rekonstruiert demnach
fliegt er am 18 juni 14 uhr 35 mit der
linienmaschine lh 882 von frankfurt nach
tallinn in estland kurz zuvor 13 uhr 16
startet ein privat jet vom typ embraer
aus der österreichischen stadt
klagenfurt ebenfalls nach tallinn
von tallinn aus fliegt die gecharterte
embraer um 17.10 nach minsk in die
hauptstadt von belarus dass er
tatsächlich in minsk ist verrät
marschalek ende juni selbst in einem
chat mit einem vertrauten wird er
gefragt ob es dort wo er gerade ist
politisch stabil sei marschalek
antwortet am 29 juni
ja sind immer noch dieselben leute am
ruder wie vor 25 jahren in europa gibt
es nur ein land in dem ein präsident so
lange im amt ist belarus unter alexander
lukaschenko
wer könnte massa lag bei seiner flucht
geholfen haben und es wird ein dass
jedes russischen geheimdienstes fsb
zugespielt danach ist der flüchtige
banker im besitz von neun verschiedenen
pässen darunter der pass eines
staatenlosen und einen diplomatenpass
marschalek war offenbar interessant für
den fsb
der geheimdienst hat 60 reisen des
österreichers nach russland dokumentiert
mehrere quellen behaupten nun erhalte
sich in der nähe von moskau auf die
suche geht also weiter nachdem banker
auf der flucht und der verantwortung für
die verschwundenen milliarden
tragen bafin und bundesregierung mit
schuld an dem skandal was meint ihr
schreibt es uns in die kommentare